when I was starting to play chess
I lost more games than everyone yeah
like if you take up all the games that
you've lost every single person in the
class and then add up that total number
you guys aren't even close to me I lost
more games than all of you combined and
many many many times my losses came in
the opening okay
in the opening I did things wrong and I
ended up getting checkmate and one of
the reasons that I lost so many games in
the opening is because I didn't protect
my king I didn't I was thinking about
whatever it was that I was thinking
about and I didn't protect my King later
much later after I had lost so many
games I learned to Castle I learned to
respect my king and get my king out of
the way so I learned a castle I love to
build a fortress that that is when you
fianchetto your Bishop and put your King
behind the bishop that was my favorite
setup and guess what when I learned to
do that I didn't lose any more in 10
moves or 15 I lost in 20 and 25 at 30
yeah I lasted a lot lot lot longer when
I learned to protect my King then when I
got even better and better and better
I started to see tactics you know the I
liked the pin and I like the knight fork
and I like the skier in the double
attack and the discovere check oh that
discovered check man that was one of my
favorites
and I learned that tactics are like
little little little tools like a screw
and there's a tactic and that you could
put all of these tactics together one
after the other after and they become a
combination a combination of forced
sequence of moves
now we're talking really really really
good
okay and I was amazed at how many
combinations there were it just seemed
like there was just one ten one hundred
three hundred a thousand even more and I
made a combination book I had a little
scrapbook and if I if I saw a nice
puzzle or something from a newspaper I
cut it out and I put it in my little
combination booklet and one of the
coolest combinations I ever learned this
is great isla galls mate how many of you
have heard of the gauls mate
Wow I'm impressed you guys are pretty
experienced players if you know the
gauls mate and this I thought was a
crime a crime can you imagine
I learned the gauls mate I memorized the
gauls mate I know it inside and out and
do you know nobody's falling for it I've
never ever in my life gotten the chance
to play lagoons made against an opponent
I mean how rotten is that I I know it I
studied it nobody ever fell for it but
it's still fun to know it okay even
though you'll probably like me in my
whole career nobody's ever let me give
the gulls mate this is lagoons mate and
I just think it's the coolest thing in
the entire world
and it goes like this
so so far White's done pretty normal
he's developed his pieces and black pins
the knight to the Queen and so it goes
pretty well and now black makes a really
bad move the only way the lagoons mate
could possibly work is if black doesn't
know what he's doing
well that meant me by the way okay I
mean you know black doesn't know what
he's doing
black should develop his knight he
should develop this Knight he could
develop his bishop he could do a lot of
good moves but black doesn't pay
attention to what's going on black plays
a poor move he just makes a pass instead
of developing his basis so he violates
the laws of strategy of opening strategy
now in this exact situation my chess
coach Geoffrey Geoffrey Parsons said to
me well what should white do what should
write to and so I thought for a moment
and I said I showed my understanding I
should said I should attack this Bishop
I should go here and attack is Bishop
but he said very good what other move
should white do and I thought not and I
was trying to remember all of the
principles and I said castles I put my
King in safety castle and my teacher
said very very good is there any other
move that you could make young man I
even though you probably know it Knight
takes e5 so this was wild to my eyes
Knight takes e5 I shot
my jaw dropped down on the ground I said
you you see I love my queen I thought
that the Queen was the most powerful
piece in the whole world and if somebody
captured my queen I couldn't play chess
my queen I can't play anymore I give up
I give up so the very idea of
sacrificing my queen
I couldn't believe so I said to my
teacher Geoffrey
that's a terrible move that's just a
terrible move because he takes the Queen
and I can just I'm lost I'm material
down I have one pawn and my opponent has
a queen and Geoffrey said don't this was
a very important lesson okay Geoffrey
said don't look at what comes off the
board study what stays on the board so
in this position Geoffrey asked me the
question Geoffrey's question to me is
the Queen has been captured what can
white do our young what do you can light
do that part I saw I saw that I could
take the pawn with check with my bishop
but I thought that I could and should
and try to do this against Geoffrey I
tried to take the pawn with the night
because I was clever I like the night
Forks right and with night takes I at
least will get the rook or the Queen for
my queen
and he said no that's not the best move
for white it's a good move not the best
our Young's move is better Bishop takes
f7 check and I said well okay
I like winning pawns with check and fact
pawns in my favorite food I like winning
pawns with check but big deal he's just
gonna move his King he moves his King
here obviously black cannot take the
bishop because the knight protects the
bishop and now comes charlie well I was
shocked I was stunned Knight d5
checkmate and this is llegaste
and I couldn't believe it
I lost my queen and in the middle of the
board the black king is checkmated this
knight on e5 protects the d7 square this
knight on e5 protects the bishop this
knight on d5 attacks the King but also
protects the f6 square and finally the
King can't go to e6 because the bishop
protects the e6 where black is checkmate
it and that pattern is called legal make
me and the moment it was shown to me I
was enchanted
oh no I wrote it down I put it in my
scrapbook and I never ever got a chance
to play it so there's a really excellent
book that I I read when I was young it
was called how to open a chess game how
to open a chess game and you know who
the author was no there were 12 there
were 12 authors grandmaster of them
Larsson Grand Master Larry heaven
Grandmaster lyusia Cordish from all over
the world the very very best
grandmasters wrote their ideas down on
what you should do in the opening and I
read this book very carefully and you
know what
they all said the same thing they use
different languages but they all said
the same thing what we're trying to do
in the opening first and foremost is to
control the center that's rule number
one that's principle number one
principle number two is we're trying to
find good squares for our pieces we want
to develop our pieces on good squares
and principle number three is pretty
good
what would you say young lady okay what
did you say safe King you want to save
King and castles helps us get a safe
King okay this is a kind of a moment for
you to ask me a kind of questions and
answer so when I was a kid I was always
always always getting into trouble in
the openings because I was violating
some principles every one of you here
have has lost a game right out of the
opening I know you have because you're
just following in my footsteps and I
trail blazed all kinds of defeats I mean
I've done everything wrong so for you if
you think about your troubles that you
have in the opening and if you could ask
a grandmaster a question about the
openings and why you're having trouble
now is a very good time anybody have a
question for me about their openings
right this is what they call the
classical center yes yes it does
I don't know what happened exactly
exactly
so we what you've described is actually
pretty perfect because we start to find
setups that we like like very much and
when we look at this setup from whites
point of view we find it attractive to
us these two ponds cover a lot of
squares the bishops are nicely placed
behind the ponds the Knights are nicely
placed behind the bishops probably we're
going to put our king over here maybe
over under the Queen side but we're
going to castle and then we kind of ask
ourselves well where are we going to
move our Queen but we don't worry about
that so we get a formation a set up that
we like and I must say this was also one
of my favorite setups and I tried that a
lot equally we could say that another
favorite setup of mine was absolutely
the same and I thought that this was
even better than the first setup why
because when our Knights were on D 2 and
E 2 our Queen didn't have much room to
move
now with our Knights on C 3 and F 3 at
least we have something like this and
then I put my king on the Kings side and
now I'm really really happy okay
another formation that I really really
really like for White was this kind of
formation so we had the two pawns here
the bishops outside of the pawns but in
my mind I had this idea like I had a
pinch a pincher kind of maneuver
I like the bishops here because one of
the things that my opponents always let
me do I mean I must it was like a magnet
for me for some reason I was really
successful in terms of capturing my
opponent's rook yes they always fell for
that
they let me come out here with the
knight my bishop would go there my
knight
bang I get the rook so this for me was
one of my more successful formations and
I like these types of things so in my
mind I was creating these formation it
was really really really rotten when my
opponents didn't let me do it
I know what I know what I want but they
would move in such a way and and I
didn't know if it was because they were
clever like they had seen me they know
that they got to stop me kind of thing
or they were just lucky most of the time
they were clever but that formation with
the bishops and the Knights later later
much later I began to respect very very
very much so and I would build a
fortress instead of putting this Bishop
on d3 or on c4 I began to realize that
according to my statistical count when I
lost I lost much longer games when I had
built a fortress for my king right like
I mean instead of losing in five moves
or ten moves or 15 moves I'd lose them
30 40 and 50 so I learned to respect the
in shadow my bishop put it on the long
diagonal where you know in my mind's eye
it was an ambush you know from my
opponent's pieces and to create a
fortress so this is like maybe Phase six
of my losing streak I still had to learn
all the bad formation